you know business making money all those
things they're all required uh to be
sustainable and continue to operate but
the most important thing is to be
intentional about uh being active in the
community and being able to give back
with our first fruits you know what we
earn
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i am
still here living in this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing to you the awareness that you
need about the gun violence on the south
side of chicago but also to raise as
much money as we possibly can to build a
community center on this block that is
much needed this block called o block
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs kept
the o in his name and started calling it
oh block we decided we're going to keep
the o but we're going to turn it into
opportunity block i want to say thank
you to fox for giving me this
opportunity to bring to you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
viewpoints
my ideas and my guests who are here to
help us in our endeavors and today i'm
so grateful to have uh with us a major
company in the city of chicago uh if
you've seen any building here in chicago
this company has probably laid the
concrete or given the concrete or sold
the concrete to make it happen uh i have
here today with me paul ozinga from
ozinga concrete and i want to jump right
in paul and just uh talk about a couple
of things
one is
i want to talk about how corporations
and companies
uh can help with the violence and i want
to talk about also what you all are
doing to help us and i think that's very
important that people know so
why do companies like ozinga i think
it's four generations right four
generations uh of rozingas who have had
ozinga concrete why is it important that
companies like yours get involved in the
city of chicago
to help as it relates to the violence
well first and foremost uh throughout
all four generations our mission as a
family has been to honor and glorify god
and serve the crown of his creation our
fellow man and so we're first guided by
that
uh direction and and so
uh when we look at that when we look
through the lens of how we're operating
our business we're saying you know is it
honoring and glorifying to god and are
we serving the communities that we're in
uh we've been uh blessed to be able to
run this business and we're called to
steward it for the time that we have it
and being in the communities that we're
in it's an it's imperative
that uh you know the community gives so
much that
we're required to give back to the
community and you know
each and every individual has unique
gifts and talents right and it's
important that um
that we're all able to use those gifts
and talents and we've been given
responsibility
to look after those gifts and talents
and it's also important that people have
purpose
and so you know we want to we want to be
able to create jobs we want to be able
to give purpose and we want to be able
to give back to the community
uh for the betterment of everybody and
by community i say you know everybody
has a responsibility to look after their
community that they're in and so it's
it's very important that that's our
that's our first priority that's our
intention
you know business making money all those
things they're all required
to be sustainable and continue to
operate but the most important thing is
to be intentional about
being active in the community and being
able to give back with our first fruits
you know what we earn that's awesome i
know we've been so blessed to have you
your company in our life for a long time
uh from the first time i was on the roof
even before that when we
first started putting our church
together you guys gave us concrete for
that when i was on the roof the first
time uh your company donated the hundred
thousand dollars to tear the building
down and uh we're grateful for that and
now we're in this endeavor where we're
trying to build this city where we're
going to build this community center to
help transform the lives of a lot of
people and you're donating concrete for
that
why why is that why why i mean i i heard
you say about the gifts talents and
skills but
what what is it that you all look for
when you get ready to donate to an
organization
so we we we really look through you know
when you go back to talking about
community i mean i'm a part of this
community you're a part of this
community
and everybody has a unique
responsibility that they've been given
and you know you
you're responsible for you know
pastoring this church for you know and
you recognize something in your
community and you're bringing awareness
around it and so we see the same
thing going on in the community and so
how how we ask ourselves you know how
can we participate when you say there's
a need
that we have in our community
and we look to see you know can we can
we help with this need with the
resources that we have
for the betterment of the community for
all of us yes and so as we look through
that lens project hood is an opportunity
for the betterment of of all of us in
our community
to to be able to
[Music]
improve and help you know the youth
within the community and so that that
really drives us uh to want to support
that to get behind that
and uh we we just really think it's a
great thing right and uh you know
one last question i know you've
donated concrete you all have hired
individuals from from our church and
we're grateful for that and
um but what do you say to
companies or
especially those in chicago or those who
are outside of chicago
what type of challenge do you give to
them
to help organizations like ours to what
type of benefit would it be for those
companies those ceos who who may be
watching and listening to us
what what may they benefit
i mean you may have heard the saying
it's more blessed to give than to
receive and
we come from
a philosophy of serving and when you
when you serve
uh what you get back is is tenfold you
know when you give
and at the end of the day you know going
back to us
been you know being given responsibility
and being stewards
uh if you look at uh the opportunities
that are in front of you and you think
that that they're of your own and of
your own you know free will and volition
that all these things occurred
uh you have to understand you know i i
look at from from
a godly perspective that you know we've
been blessed in this way
it's all his and and we need to be
giving back uh to what he's provided for
us and so
uh if you look at it that way you know
we're all dealing with different things
as individuals and
and if you needed help you would hope
that there would be somebody that would
step up and provide that help
and
here uh in this community
uh we need help
and so it's important that you step up
and provide that help whether it's
whether it's through material whether
it's monetary whether it's physical you
know
there is there is a need and uh creating
awareness around this need
uh is is another gift and and you're
doing it and so if anybody has the
ability to help where it's needed it's
critical to the betterment of our
community
i agree well paul as always i want to
say thank you and thanks to all your
brothers and other concrete for being a
blessing to us and um that's what it's
all about um people coming to the aid of
one another to assist us to make the
world a better place and when we do that
we can all make america a better place
thank you once again to fox for giving
me the opportunity to give you rooftop
revelations and as i always say until
tomorrow
peace
you